yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
hello to all of you in the chat yeah
I've got a couple of regulars already
already in and I'm happy to start this
this blitz session here on the ICC let's
see what we get here
um five minutes yes of course I'm going
to request the game and also Happy New
Year by the way yeah it's already the
fourth of July but still a fourth of
July 4th of January fourth of July
brother January so happy to welcome you
all to the first session of of the CM ok
playing the drama da here and what is he
doing here why do I have to be alert you
see five isn't that a good move ok hmm
kind of surprised that this is supposed
to be good that's Jasper Hall and the
drama down I think 96 this 95 this is
something that I should be should be
aware of maybe just a 6 and he goes g4
Wow
yeah it's a pretty strong I am I've ever
had a history against him in many of
many blitz games and the user picture is
that I'm completely winning and he's
tricking me with no time on the clock so
we'll see if this pattern continues on
if I can somehow manage to play a gay
player plagued straightforward game not
allowing anything ok um
h4 is kind of aggressive there on the
kingside and he's playing quickly okay
I'm going to try to gain some space down
and see what he's doing
okay maybe take em I don't like what's
position I think this is not good
I've got play against the center here
and he's mostly weakened himself for
example he doesn't have a clear position
of his king f5 yeah probably five Oh is
he going g5 maybe is going g5
huh whatever should flick in age 6 cm
g5d 5 that's kind of annoying and E 5 g
5 I'm sorry
okay I'm flicking in age 6 preventing g
5 it's a bit slow okay as usual he's not
reacting to my play at all
look b1 okay that was probably the idea
okay I just go back to c7 yeah I think
white is in bad shape but it's a it's a
complicated position and I'm down on
time yeah hello to a couple of others
who now have joined the chat and happy
new years okay if I class well he might
have g5 this kind of as kind of
attacking ideas but I have to get the
rook into the game so let's castle for
rupee aid
hello also 233 McNuggets he's new
new here best of luck yeah thanks let's
do this threatening Knight f3 and let's
see how to how to kill white now
okay let's do this let's do something
simple he has to take this and then my
queen is entering the game quickly no
you can offer offer draws in a row let's
say but it's considered a bit if you're
constantly constantly offer draws this
is considered a bad sportsmanship and is
distracting the opponent so you
shouldn't offer draws all the time but
it's okay if you offer a draw and then
like 30 moves later do it again there's
nothing wrong with that
okay okay I have to be forceful here
pawn takes that's ninety four and this
is this is not losing any time this is
the thing and I look before maybe anyway
if he constantly offers draws you can
call the ref yes the arbiter I
definitely would do that because it's
really bad sportsmanship constantly
offering draws
yeah it's a good position for me but so
tricky
yeah punch the opponent in the face is a
somewhat uncommon way to do it but it's
effective I'm pretty sure they stop what
they're doing still I think they have
pretty good arguments with the arbiter
if they got punished in the face
couple of things here threatening rook
t4 but also of just piling up not sure
what he's doing here
look see one maybe rook see one now that
could be a move and quick Queen takes d4
is not I mean rook takes d4 maybe I get
tons of pawns now probably Roxy one look
tasty for me okay taking this also I
have Queen takes a two in some cases
yeah there's some of the chat cards
books are nice and here I can say my
rooks are nice aren't they
so just rope cheat one come on keep it
simple for roopd two that will be very
tough to defend okay um he has check on
F on CN n f5 this is something I rocked
it - what about Canada not just the wind
'red rook the rook is unprotected here
that comes with a chick
yeah white resins that was I'm a mapping
that was good I think he was very
exposed to his his position was very
exposed okay let's shoot for a new game
okay that was Maradona again I had him I
think lost William and in a session so
I'm playing the Queens gambit accepted
here and see what he's doing I'm going
with this funky move Knight a three
uh-huh okay let's develop yeah I saw the
dot the dot World Championships a little
bit
yeah Gary Anderson at one point failed
to count correctly I think it probably
did it can happen there in the in those
in those situations yeah I'm planning
for c5 here we go and with a funny
maneuver I put my bishop on a good
square on d5
hmm eighty-three seems he wants to take
maybe I'm taking myself
it's an interesting move but I think I
probably will keep that Bishop for the
time being
yeah well that's fine funny about the
world championships and dances then it
always makes me feel like even without
losing weight I could be a top player I
mean I think it seems to be if you're
not at least like 3040 pounds overweight
you seem to have no particular chance in
being in the event kind of funny
yeah why doesn't a little bit yeah I
think the main point with there with the
the dark players being overweight a set
I mean they they probably hang around in
in pops all the time to practice right
and well hmm what can you do not so sure
95
ninety-two what's an interesting
okay let's go back
yeah of course everybody had their
career choices I'm doing chess nowadays
but also for course could have done
something else the only thing that
really interests that had an interest in
it school a lot was actually history and
also I liked English but history mostly
and I wasn't yeah I mean I didn't mind
yeah physics and stuff like that but I
never found it particularly interesting
was found history very fascinating
because it's not so easy to grasp with
pure mathematics or or
yeah some equations or something like
that it's just far more difficult to get
get a grip with Queen d6
I'm not sure that's an interesting move
I'm trying Bishop g5 and run to prevent
a form but a tough position
hmm yeah
22 hmm how am I playing this I'm just
here I guess looking at deform what is
the two-minute rule so that basically
answers your question the question is
someone asked am i familiar with the
two-minute rule and my answer is No
yeah there are some tricky points in
history where it's not quite clear if
the if the if it really happened like
that I mean there are there are cases
where a couple of years maybe missing or
so in the in the chronology group I
cannot pronounce it good yeah in the
what what would is known but it is not
not that bad
it's not like everything's wrong
everything's unclear some came mr. Queen
down yes g3 actually I didn't think
about that more
and I have to but I have some chances
here of course with here with this King
position Bishop you form there is a 92
night a five maybe four night age for I
have to be cautious here with possible
possible mates my background is a bit
weak ish I can take the rookin c7 is
hanging
it's pretty pretty awkward it's 94 move
or that's a [ __ ] I'm going for that
night on b3 assign
Knight age three now in the mix I don't
want to trade Queens that's pretty clear
so let's go back
I didn't think about that one
threatening made now on f3 it's pretty
bad yeah I lost some time but while it's
now also losing
yeah the two-minute rule I mean if I'm
if I see that correctly it's a rule that
you could claim a draw if it's under two
minutes the thing is um it's simply
avoidable if you play an increment time
controller at the end and you just let
the guys play it out the ideal situation
is that the arbiter has absolutely
nothing to do the arbiter should never
in any any moment be required to know
chess because this is a big issue with
arbiters quite often they have no idea
about the game and you simply cannot
give him any influence over the results
I have seen so many video tech things
happen back then when we didn't have
incremental controls there was one
situation like more than 20 years ago
when there was a game between a
grandmaster and an amateur player and it
was a totally dead rook and game and
amateur player claimed to draw and and
they had a let's say normal arbiter and
achieve arbiter and the normal habit oh
he wiped no idea about the game and he
said okay we will continue varla blah
mostly because the grandmaster was kind
of oh I can continue I can continue and
unfortunately the chief arbiter who was
about him master strength he was just
nearby and he said you know what this is
a drawing I speak witness nonsense and
then the game was ended yeah this is
good a good result in this particular
case because there wasn't habit around
who actually know something about the
game but you can absolutely not allow
some I mean there are people with the
1500 rating who are arbiters in the
German Bundesliga this is just
ridiculous the only thing you can accept
that is that you limit their scope of
influence to absolutely nothing or the
least possible because you can never
allow a situation where they actually
have to judge if something is a draw or
something is a try for win or not it's
that absolutely cannot happen
yeah we have a main lining of the Bishop
f4 Queen's Gambit and after qa5 I have
to think I'm not sure is it rook t1 or
92 I always forget yeah I think the
arbiter stage simply they need rules
that make it a rookie a that is Carles
move here right from the word
championship match
this is a thing yeah I think I mean they
they they simply need rules that makes
it possible to do it with the outturn
without knowing so much chess I think
this is possible
yeah there's a there's a mention of them
of an alternative history historical
timeline then Kasparov beliefs that is
correct this is of course utterly at a
total nonsense I mean complete nonsense
and really a very questionable by an
intelligent persons or you would believe
intelligent person like a sparrow is
thinking this is true of course you can
question certain things in the timeline
but it it's not like everything is wrong
what was in them okay what is this he's
allowing me to take on f6 that's kind of
surprising okay I'll take that
let's get them yeah the thing is it
doesn't matter if he's fifteen hundred
rating the the thing is the game has to
be played out and it's it shouldn't
really matter if they what kind of
rating they have so I'm kind of mmm
I wonder if I'm doing this right here
anyway
let's shoot looks like 95 that's
probably not a big deal
uh-huh okay II five he will take
unfortunately
let's do this prepare you five my Bishop
g7 maybe I'm making go Bishop g7
yeah Bishop g7 is good yeah he is get
95n
he will get 95 and there are very funny
things in history there even people who
believe that Shalamar card and goose I
am in German that he actually never
lived that it's not a historical person
this I found very funny because we have
tons of tons of evidence about that and
I mean completely ridiculous I mean this
is something that you can actually find
find honey I mean even worse is of
course the that you still have people to
claim that the Holocaust never happened
with which is kind of completely crazy I
mean not just from from a purely ethical
point of Huber's also from a purely
factual point of view completely crazy
because the Holocaust is one of the best
documented things in the Newman history
yeah terrible things you two have talked
to have to document well but it is
actually completely clear that then it
happened okay anyway the game that I
never really focused on what happens now
I wanted to go 95 but that actually
Bloodless the supership so maybe cover
that
mm okay neighs playing this no I gave
you five in though I'm happy to have
that end
ya know 94-96 that was my idea do I get
that in hmm I never get to have six
really him probably not
shoot 95 hmm that's not great
and five I found surprising a for now
seems very weak
well maybe it's got Queen d6 and my back
rank okay let's do something about the
back rank
oh I have to speed up
come on bloody nonsense ya lost one time
yeah and he says thank you the automatic
thank you which is always kind of beep
you after the game like that okay anyway
okay new game no I didn't study our
informatics no I studied but not for
very long time history and and English
language and then I switch to to learn
at a bank directly I had always had
problems with studies and universities
because it wasn't so well organized you
know I mean you could you can attend a
class or you cannot write they basically
am yeah it's your business to organize
yourself and always what to play chess
instead so it kind of didn't work out I
ultimately decided to to learn at this
Bank well this was not this was bad
actually Bishop takes piayed
this might still be okay yeah more
viewer games yes I'm sorry that question
has been post now number of times it's
on my radar but currently and it's
nothing that will happen in the next
couple of weeks
definitely not I'm having a move change
of apartment ahead of me and this is
taking most of my my time I Scott would
be one I didn't see that one I it's bad
I didn't see that the rook is actually
protected
now maybe I can have to play this yeah
you can still get my book directly from
me you send me a message by mail that
would work fine look here they move the
Queen away I'm I'm not moving far away
from the current place moving back to my
hometown
ciao is playing this well
the book is I'm just charging the
regular retail price from chest book
retailers with 25 euros um plus them the
shipping costs
yeah I'm down that pornea and
unfortunately and let's hope for some
counterplay no I don't live with family
I'm I'm single the most underestimated
opening probably they're a couple
there are a couple of openings that are
underestimated one thing for example
that is a pretty decent is it's the
Queens gambit accepted that's an that's
an that's an opening that I think black
is very much okay with the red t opening
has become a little bit more popular in
the last couple of years when people
trying to avoid avoid the come on they
the Berlin they have more and more come
to appreciate the the flank openings
yeah I'm trying to get some kind of
count to play him but not not easy now
93 93 might be enough threatening on a
to when 92 antiques I think that should
be enough to draw the game I've I've the
the the live shows here on Monday our
regular feature they are basically on on
every Monday I sometimes stream on my
own channel but not not as often
okay now I'm entertaining hopes of
winning the game am I too optimistic
maybe I am
hmm okay I first want the porn back yeah
I'm not I'm not something hmm I'm not
really in a position to tell about Buffy
fish's state of mind I mean I don't
think the term crazy is something that
is would be used by someone who's
knowledgeable about psychology but yeah
it's definitely lame hisses it certainly
wasn't an easy person or something like
that
ha that's a good move
look it's rocky 7 I wrote a seven he has
to check on e eight and then go on the
eighth-ranked this is a bit of an
annoyance irony do I have to play
passively Wow
hmm okay I don't want on hmm what is
this alrighty way
I wanted to take and blunder wow that's
a great idea great idea hmm
okay yes five actually strong move
I've got to have seconds left I didn't
pay any attention to the clock eeeh
oh my
drunky he tricked me to meet there but I
simply didn't look at the clock and that
was pretty pretty awful ah the thing is
there is a discussion of our chess
players and their IQ this is actually
very debate very debatable for example
Kasparov psyche us there are various
reports about that that he's like on 180
or 90 or whatever but there's also
people claiming he was tested with one
135 it's it's tough to tell those tests
are are difficult I think most of those
claims they are kind of not founded on
or supported by official testing and
even even the official IQ tests are
tricky
there are various ones
okay we go for animals Oh him hmm lost
quite a bit of points I really want to
get those back no I don't have any
tournaments planned at the moment yeah I
think that that excuse of the best chess
players probably clearly above average
but it's something that is also the case
for many other people excelling in their
field someone mentioned Formula One
drivers I have no idea about those
people but I think that it's it's clear
that they also have to be intelligent to
to handle them they're very cook
correctly and the things that they do
around it's just more than just driving
if they have to test and things
okay so getting some nice active play
yeah but as usual it is complicated
Wow okay
job that looks tough yeah for both sides
to play okay I have to get something
going him and definitely prevent him
from castling long yeah this is
interesting now sacrifice
yeah I have to get a grave to prevent
long castles so let's get ahead and
sacrifice his pieces are all on the
Queen side sitting around so I'm not
sure that this works but I think it
makes some sense
so f5 you're going to wear out to eight
there's a check first him
f-five kini aids but chicken h5 and King
to g8 the problem is a little bit then I
can I think I still have to do it you
can take suffice my problem this is the
issue yeah probably this is not a
correct sacrifice but it's ok it was
interesting
okay let's threaten route g7 the problem
is that it's very easy to spot but still
you can try how is he defending this
actually 9065 no this one okay I'm happy
to take this is why it has the same
issue so dangerous sometimes you just
get checkmates and okay it was probably
incorrect so let's do one more at least
one more playing I'll calm
let's try something else let's play the
check in on him
yeah trying for trying for some
long-term play on the kingside who is
this person by the way
no no name okay night a four is a bit
surprising not sure what the night is
doing there now I have never played the
snake Benoni and it's not particularly
great ok mr. Khan I know what I'm doing
I'm going f4 g5 age 5 and trying to hit
you over the head with a big frying pan
what is your play
yeah this is what I expected yes some
kind of sacrifice to get something going
I have my doubts though that is
objectively working we should have six I
thought it couldn't be true maybe anyway
I'm going to play it or 23m I can take
it but okay he's not threatening that
much I believe every three maybe
let's go let's go there
Bishop age three that's actually pretty
ridiculous because of rook F - hmm
and three was bad when I was a bad move
okay anyway Queen h4 takes Teague's yeah
I can't let's get this going and ladies
got three points now
and
Wow I don't want to play root g8 that's
kind of awful
for cream III check
and I didn't see rupees seven at all I
don't think white sacrifice worked
absolutely not but I thought that this
is draw maybe I'm wrong
I don't see how he avoids the the draw
King h1 through h6 I think it's drawn is
cutting edge too hot you're right you
skis got Queen edge too
okay so I can take d3 now with check
King edge for root g8 are you winning
then let's see
she doing tween f6 or something like
that I'm down on time this is the thing
now okay this is Vonage this is a good
move probably Luke f5 is made huh okay
that was good yeah okay that's very good
that's very good that's pretty bad now
that is a game that should have won
because white played this pretty
terribly actually up to a certain point
here here black hippy black is just
winning I mean this is just just awful
but I played it really badly afterwards
after he sacrificed a piece f3 was bad
pretty bad okay so let's get a final
gaming for today I'm playing hog a I've
got white why do I have white rook I
have seven results King f7 the King edge
simmers also look h5 mate whole game
with white yeah I never have white
against him I always have black and have
to play as b3 stuff boys and he lost
some Roxy yeah that's fine that's nice
let me talk to you a little bit in the
maroc see I really did have a bad score
him in this session so I will really
want a winnin
yeah I always have black again subscribe
and plays 1 1 B 3 stuff he doesn't play
d4 b6 unfortunately I think he tried
once and got checkmated
well it's important to understand that
one b3 is fairly okay it's really okay
equal yeah have many openings are equal
but in comparison should have planned
and let's do this now my rook is
actually wrong down on c1
but anyway should have gone for that
with rook rook on a1 and well b3 is is
really okay beef b3 is really okay but
one b6 against d4 is really bad I mean
this is not a good opening d 4b 64 is
just good for white
okay Bishop g5 might be a move
54 salsals yeah and then double on the
e-file I have lost some time yet
fortunately
I'm just blundering the bishop what am I
doing here you can just take that oh my
god boom boom wow that's a really bad
session I'm sorry about that
that's really embarrassing I simply I
simply didn't see that he can take it
there was my own novel plan there was my
own idea oh my god I'm just I'm sorry
this is just crazy okay I cannot end the
session with this kind of game I need
one more game wow that really happens to
me I mean I make my fair share of bad
moves but just giving a piece in one
movies is kind of an unusual Wow poor
yeah did a long day but still okay let's
let's beat this guy III okay
I see something going to go full
concentration out here to win this
in case playing the CMS variation that's
interesting with Ruby wanna okay
now I'm keeping commentary a little bit
short this time because I absolutely
want to win this game because of the
earlier results of the session it's
already terrible session anyway but I
want to win this game at least have one
good game in 96 possibly five but still
is the the normal way to play this I can
also take a look see a rooks the editor
often a good choice trying to take on
default econ see for next okay what now
1965 92 for it's always some danger
involved with that keeping it closed
and I think he would probably go eat
five now I was thinking f5 but Bishop g5
is kind of annoying oh okay I'm happy to
do that
complicated position very complicated
trying to get the night over looking at
a five
95 for trade who okay let's try to trade
this
hmm okay maybe he's going Bishop f4 here
therefore trying to pry this open with
e5 huh that's difficult very difficult
to to defend I think I have to keep the
e5 point hmmm that's a bit awkward I
don't want to play age six or g6 or
something like that and is threatening
Bishop f4 in 85
okay I'm going to allow the sacrifice
I'm going to give them give him the
exchange
and unfortunately fortunately this is
possible
a bishop
if the bishop gets back to c8 his rook
is actually trapped so maybe this is
something queen h5 though Wow okay right
over to d6 yeah maybe I can get one of
the pawns ultimately
he always has greenish v stuff
not so easy for him to to win this I
think
yeah Bishop 1/4 this is an interesting
interesting possibility him trying to
take one of the pawns I mean not trying
I will take one of the pawns but this is
the thing I am queen g4 beat him hmm
he's also playing very strong this guy
not just that I'm playing badly he's
also playing in a very strong way him
hmm maybe this isn't so bad all of a
sudden but take here between age five is
always the problem here I can keep up
take tweenage five I'm a queen each
tribe is not threatening that much but
queen g4 is I have to play I'm just to
slow him to free and slow Queen h4 I
should have played by taking this pawn
let's do it now
yeah we'll take so that I can if he
wants to get to the apron yes to give a
before I'll give me some other kind of
counterplay
it's probably not ending well while what
a bad session really hated playing that
badly I could have taken c3 and I lost
some time yeah you know there was a
really bad session what did i do there
what did I do in this friggin session
did I really lose all yeah and I want
something at them at the beginning right
I won the first two and then lost five
out of six Wow and I didn't play the
greatest guys ever pretty awful Wow
anyway I have to wrap it up here it is
it is really necessary been a very long
day ok guys I hope you still enjoyed the
session we had all kinds of talk about
various subjects also some chess but
also some other stuff I hope you still
enjoyed the first session of this year
I'll be back next Monday with the new
one and also take note that there is
some you happening against ICC members
on Saturday I will announce that of
course will be played against ICC
members everybody can watch though there
will be a separate announcement view for
that thanks a lot guys bye bye